so this morning yet again Ukraine came
under attack from multiple Russian
missiles hitting multiple regions
there's the mayor in zaparisia one of
the big cities in southern eastern
Ukraine said that 17 missiles struck he
said that that was the the largest
number of missiles in one go hitting
that City since the full-scale invasion
was launched by Russia a year almost a
year ago there's also been missile
strikes in harkiv in the Northeast in
Kiev here in denipro overnight and the
sky team heard the sound of explosions
as a number of drones were shot out of
the sky Ukraine's air defense system has
been working incredibly hard yet again
trying to protect the infrastructure
that these Russian missiles seem to be
going after but of course some get
through officials saying that a number
of s-300 missiles were used by Russia
and their defense systems just can't
shoot them down and so yes we are
hearing once again for those desperate
pleas for more air defense systems of
course we've also had those pleas from
the president himself on his tour of you
of Europe and the UK for fast Jets the
aircraft that the ukrainians have their
Soviet era ones The Radars aren't great
it makes it very difficult for those
aircraft to be able to shoot missiles
and drones out the sky